embarn tôi muốn li tảo trong video mcke Đoc ngược rồi
đoán giấu vị trời
cái trẻ lại
đoán giống nhưng chúng tôi chưa ạ
bởi vậy, mởi vậy, chúng không đoán giống l VM
và những vẻ có lạy t Summit
và có lạy t Summit
chào tìm có người trời
và hẹn gặp tế
Thật sự, cái khu vĩ tét rất nhiều một vụ.
Nhưng rất rất là.
Dì em, để ai em rất đi.
Mời mới năm, người rất là hảo vĩ đi đó, tét là giọng được.
Tết trên tàu không trạng ở đâu, động chỉ trạng ở đâu, sẽ gòn.
Thống này, nó này, nó đặc biệt.
Nó có cái xe của cộng đàu.
Bình chung cuối, các khách khóc để đọt được.
Có ý chương trình.
Trời ơi, rất tràn, có ý chương phần trường.
Chào dạc.
Có thường, trạm, và ăn bạch kèo qua qua.
Vậy, vâng, chúc 1 năm mới, rồi anh thách tạm để là...
... em cũng cần đứa hơn.
Vậy, tạm phải xảy máy nhất trong suốt gài chạy.
Vì ở đây đâu rồi rồi.